[Musica]
buonasera
non so quanti di voi hanno confidenza
con la parola illustratore e sanno
magari cosa fa io vi do un indizio
solitamente non calcano palchi come
questo quindi perdonatemi magari se sono
un pochino pochino emozionato ho detto
questo il ristoratore semplicemente è
una persona è una persona che disegna
disegna per vivere e disegni che fa non
sono quelli che siamo abituati a pensare
nel senso quelli che abbiamo fatto tutti
da ragazzini quando facevamo le
elementari o banalmente quelli che noi
facciamo quando magari siamo al telefono
che prendiamo scarabocchiato lì sul
taccuino gli illustratori disegna con
una finalità differente che non è quella
di decorare non è quella appunto di
intrattenersi nel senso una finalità
appunto illustrativa disegna per
spiegare dei concetti che di fair che
sono troppo complessi per poter essere
rappresentati diversamente
viviamo in un nel mondo della
complessità dove ormai non lo so io vi
faccio sempre porto sempre questo
esempio la fotografia non riesce più a
descrivere tutto banalmente chiedete a
un fotografo di descrivervi e la blog
chain con uno scatto fotografico è una
questione abbastanza tricky nel senso è
difficile ed è in supporto appunto di
per questo motivo nel senso che entrano
in ballo per professionalità come la mia
quindi l'illustratore altro non è che un
progettista del visivo al pari di lo so
un grafico un videomaker un fotografo e
e il suo compito è praticamente quello
di aiutare nella comprensione la
comprensione di qualsiasi cosa nel senso
che io lavoro principalmente nel lato
vertising e nell'editoria
ma chi fa il mio mestiere in generale
gli illustratori di concetto altro non
fanno che appunto essere d'ausilio alla
comprensione di qualsiasi tipo di testo
tra l'altro quando parlo di testo
prendo in prestito questa parola dalle
elezioni di semiotica delle università
quindi contesto io intendo qualsiasi
arti fatto umano in grado di comunicare
qualcosa che in grado di portare con sé
del senso quindi sì siamo delle pesti
rare comunque perché comunque non ce ne
sono tantissimi e non so quanti di voi
nella loro vita hanno sentito mai la
necessità di rivolgersi ad un
professionista tipo come come me è molto
raro anche qui dentro in questo stato in
questa platea non ci siano degli addetti
ai lavori è veramente difficile sentire
la necessità di commissionare
l'illustrazione a qualcuno però
esistiamo e anche se in realtà non siamo
proprio come la cultura di massa ci
dipinge ovvero non so qualcosa di molto
simile ad un pittore con una maglietta a
righe e un cappello un basco tipo un
cavalletto e un pennello mentre
dipingiamo en plen air dati sulle rive
della senna
esistiamo facciamo una vita
probabilmente molto meno interessante e
molto anche manchi molto più triste
perché son sempre rigo avviso il tavolo
da disegno o comunque sul foglio di
lavoro di illustrator e e noi lo
facciamo il nostro ruolo che farci
venire delle idee far scoccare la
scintilla
siamo appunto una categoria
professionale chiedi i guizzi lampi di
ingegno e scintille ha fatto
praticamente il modo per sbarcare il
lunario per pagare il mutuo dell'affitto
e quindi quando mi è stato chiesto
appunto di salire su questo palco li di
parlarvi ho pensato che forse sarebbe
stato interessante raccontarvi di quello
che c'è
prima del quello che viene prima della
scintilla perché sì c'è qualcosa che
viene prima della scintilla e quel
qualcosa si chiama creative process il
processo creativo processo creativo che
altro non è che metodologia progettuale
questo significa aver praticamente come
posso spiegarvi le in maniera
semplicissima processo creativo non è
nient'altro che praticamente una specie
di tramoggia gigantesca da dove vengono
buttati dei dati grezzi e che gli
permettono appunto di riuscire poi dopo
tutta una serie di processi che io mette
in atto di tirar fuori poi quella che è
l'idea per realizzare una illustrazione
raccontandola in maniera tipo matematica
il il processo creativo altro non è che
un un algoritmo non importante quale
dato io inserisco dentro l'importante il
processo che nel bene o nel male mi
porterà comunque ad un risultato
pertanto io in questi giorni ho cercato
un attimino di riflettere appunto su su
quello che il processo creativo e su
come io lo ha adattato tipo a me stesso
ed al mio lavoro io sono riuscito
praticamente a tirare fuori ad
individuare tre macro fasi della
progettazione
la prima è quella del dell'analisi
doveva annualmente nel senso dopo una
prima fase in cui io raccolgo i dati che
sono banalmente il brief mi concentro
poi sull'analisi del contesto vedete
contesto è una delle parole più
importanti per un illustratore perché e
dalla comprensione del contesto che io
riesco a capire con chi sto parlando e
come devo parlare perché concorderete
con me col fatto che se io progetto
qualcosa che deve finire sul new york
times
utilizzerò un linguaggio un tono e non
lo so un approccio diverso che dopo
quello che potrei invece utilizzare per
gli risulta per il reader's digest che è
ovviamente una rivista più popolare no
quindi conoscenza del contesto significa
conoscenza del supporto su dove sto
dove andrà a finire l'amministrazione
conoscenza del del target conoscenza
anche della cultura del posto in cui il
mio prodotto cioè il prodotto della mia
creatività
no verrà calato
io racconta sempre io insegno in alcune
università private e racconti sempre
questa storiella qui la prima volta che
mi è arrivata la mia prima grossa
commissione da parte di una rivista tipo
americana
ora non ricordo il new yorker ogni coi
new york magazine
mi chiesero di realizzare un
illustrazione sul riciclaggio di denaro
a facile ho pensato banalmente prendo il
symbol etto tipo del riciclaggio le tre
freccine che si rincorrono sostituisco
le treccine a delle banconote da un
dollaro ed è perfetto cazzo figata sono
un cazzo di drago benissimo tutto
orgoglioso prendono mando all'art
director e il tizio mi fa bella
ma cos'è e io gli spiego tipo tutta la
vicenda è lui fa benissimo ma noi qui il
denaro lo l'abbiamo perché in italia
noi lo ricicliamo ma negli stati uniti e
monella un the ring il denaro viene
lavato quindi questo significa conoscere
conoscere essere a conoscenza del
contesto significa appunto conoscere la
lingua la storia e conoscere
praticamente qualsiasi sfaccettatura
anche le fa le frasi idiomatiche nel
senso concorrono a renderci progettisti
migliorino sun soo nell'arte nella
guerra diceva che appunto era importante
conoscere il terreno di della battaglia
per potersi aggiudicare la vittoria a
questa segua a questa prima fase ne
segue una seconda che è invece una fase
di ricerca la ricerca che viene fatta
tipo parallelamente su due campi
la prima è di tipo concetto e
contenutistico banalmente mi viene
chiesto nell'illustrazione sulla glock
chain sono digiuno riguardo a blog chain
devo necessariamente informarmi su
quell'argomento mentre la seconda è di
tipo stilistico barra morfologico cosa
significa che è una ricerca che tifa
l'illustratore e
è portato a fare costantemente ed è
quella ricerca che arricchisce il
proprio iperuranio ora non so quanto
abbiate dimestichezza con questo termine
io l'ho imparato praticamente al liceo
durante le ore di filosofia l'iperuranio
è il luogo delle idee manenti dove
praticamente vi faccio ad esempio io non
conservo tutti i ricordi banalmente devo
disegnare un cane nell'iperuranio io
conservo l'idea di cane che è diverso
dal conservare il ricordo di qualsiasi
cane che ho visto tipo da quando sono
alto così fino adesso perché nel mio di
per ora neo che poi non è nient'altro
che una banca dati di immagini
praticamente io archivio le
caratteristiche fondamentali che rendono
il cane differente da un qualsiasi altro
quadrupede e è sembrerà banale ma questo
permette ad un illustratore di come dire
distinguersi dagli altri colleghi perché
se c'è una cosa che è veramente
importante nel mondo dimostrazione dello
stile e lo stile non è nient'altro che
quello che noi riusciamo praticamente a
produrre senza l'aiuto di influenze
esterne no e quando praticamente noi
prendiamo qualcosa dal nostro iperuranio
e la facciamo passare attraverso il
filtro delle nostre esperienze personali
della nostra sensibilità a questa
seconda fase poi segue la terza che è
quella di composizione dove praticamente
l'illustratore inizia praticamente a
ragionare per associazioni di idee
e succede qualcosa che è molto simile a
quando avete per esempio tantissime
tessere di un puzzle è banalmente
provato ad incastrare robe che non è
proprio in un match sono perfettamente
perché ci affanniamo per fare questo per
costruire immagini scenari che sono
inconsueti e che possano in qualche
maniera offrire un modo diverso di
vedere le cose e magari suggerire anche
delle soluzioni
e un po come adesso non so se ve lo
ricordate però tempo fa qualche estate
fa c'era tempo del tipo che aveva tirato
fuori quel tormentone orribile tempo in
apple bolpin no l'illustratore fa
praticamente questo ho una mela o una
penna apple penna ecco perché queste
feste ed è in questo momento qui e che
appunto si verifica la scintilla no è il
momento in cui appunto poi arrivano le
idee però come potete vedere non è una
cosa così istantanea come siamo abituati
a sentirci a raccontare perché il
processo che porta all'arrivo cioè alla
produzione di una scintilla è un
qualcosa di lento e faticoso la
progettazione che è quello che in realtà
io vorrei quasi forse spingere questa
sera è come quando tipo c'è e come lo
stracotto di cinghiale nel senso è una
roba è una pentola che borbotta che
bolle a fuoco lento
le idee cuocere a fuoco lento poi si
manifestano in maniera lampante ma tutto
quello che c'è dietro
è un lavoro molto lungo e pertanto oggi
la mia riflessione forse è proprio
questa nel senso riconoscere alla
progettazione e al processo creativo il
ruolo che merita il ruolo di matrice
delle scintille praticamente pertanto vi
chiedo congedandomi di fare un applauso
al processo creativo
se lo merita grazie
[Musica]